[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
day for Kamala Harris during an event uh
with the starkly uh Black College
University students at the White House
the audience had to be reminded to clap
for the vice president you really can't
make this up take a look please stand as
she enters the room
[Music]
you can clap
they still didn't clap
then it got worse with yet another rant
about you know Venn diagrams watch this
the latest thing she's uh talking about
a lot of things in the context of a Venn
diagram I love Venn diagrams always ask
is there a Venn diagram for this I'm
telling you it's fascinating when you do
so Vander item those three circles right
and if you want to add some more circles
to the Venn diagram
the solutions also look like what we
need to do to invest in a clean energy
economy that's what it is just like the
passage of time that's when Time
Passages and passing and it's passing
time
I didn't make that up
session with these Venn diagrams as she
says has been a constant theme of hers
now as vice president in case you've
forgotten take a look
and what we are also seeing
is that if you look at you know I like
Venn diagrams okay so if you look I do
so let me tell you um I love Venn
diagrams
I love Venn diagrams you know the three
circles I love Venn die you're just
cracking up right among the many things
that I like I love Venn diagrams
[Laughter]
you know the three circles I love Venn
diagrams I just like just throw it into
a Venn diagram I'll tell you everything
you need to know about any issues I love
Venn diagrams let me just I really just
love Venn diagrams I love Venn diagrams
okay that's just a little I really do I
love Venn diagrams and you know the
three circles sometimes there are more
I don't know what she likes better Venn
diagrams or giggling
the White House's flubs didn't end there
you won't believe what happened during
today's press briefing take a look at
this
so today as you all saw just an hour or
so ago President Obama announced that
the person invited whoa
that is news
[Applause]
one wonders who really is in charge
don't they
you're joining us now with our great
great American panel the co-hosts of the
bottom line Dagen McDowell Sean Duffy
and Cox Across America host Jimmy phela
thank you
wow
Jimmy what's event what's a Venn diagram
with three circles do you know
you know the worst part of that story is
Biden thinks it's a guy named Ben
diagram
she loves him so much I want to meet
this guy she's always talking
about I have no idea but maybe you can
help us taking
well you learn them in third grade that
we always think that she's speaking like
she talks to adults like their children
it's really the other way around yeah
she's she's stuck in third grade that's
when the learning ceased I thought
though she didn't wasn't really that
upset about the students clapping for
her she walked in there feeling saucy
and sassy and vivacious and Alive
because she's not Pete bootage yeah
that's probably true I had one thing I
just want to correct the record though
the only reason they didn't clap is it
was one in the afternoon and they didn't
want to wake up Biden
it was just nap time and I'm saying yeah
Sean I when I I don't I worry about him
running again and ever winning that
scares the hell out of me but then I
worry about her running and I don't know
what scares me more her or him so I
think that's the point of the Democrats
right they look at Kamala Harris and
she's on serious sometimes it looks like
she's smoking dope
um and they look and go listen Joe Biden
is the only hope we have because if it's
not Joe we based our whole political
career on identity politics we can't
send uh Kamala Harris out to Pastor so
they can't have Kamala so they're stuck
with Joe and it's um by the way think
what the Chinese they watch Joe Biden
and they watch Kamala Harris how
unserious do they think we are how
stupid they think we are that we'd like
these two in the top positions of the US
I look at everything that's happening
and I see you know I see China on the
move I see Russia on the move I see the
economy Lauren Summers is warning of a
real economic crash taking you follow
this you both followed us and and we
have really serious problems and I just
don't think they're up to fixing any one
of these problems I don't think they
understand the intricacies of an economy
I don't think they understand what's
really going on in terms of Ukraine I
worry about the bidens being compromised
I got a lot of thoughts spinning in my
head about where things can go and none
of them seem to be going in the right
direction well number one energy
destroying our energy sector driving up
Energy prices that gave Vladimir Putin
enough money to invade Ukraine and now
this fixation on green energy that's
funneling money directly to China and it
is it is destroying our way of life and
it is destroying
um our standard of living and I've said
this to you before debt is weakness so
just on the amount of debt that they've
accumulated in two years has made
America a great deal you saw the CBO
numbers what another 10 trillion dollars
in debt in a short period of time uh
looking down the line at 50 trillion
dollars in debt jet uh debt to GDP ratio
now uh over a hundred percent it's
normally about 46 percent then 125 right
now and so listen they know what they're
doing they're the people inside the
White House they're smart they're trying
to tank the American economy they're
trying to destroy America because they
hate America you don't you don't do this
you think for any other reason but that
is true you think they're doing this on
purpose
oh a hundred percent uh why they want to
transform America right there's a this
is a transformational presidency Barack
Obama started it Joe Biden is going to
finish it the middle class Americans be
damned this is about an elite ruling
class A globalist idea so that's the
reason why that we have all this energy
all these resources here but they'd
rather import three million barrels of
oil for Venezuela a day and batteries
from China
listen I shouldn't be questioning
anybody's handling of money based on
this jacket that I paid money for
wait a minute yeah that wasn't a
dumpster dive stop it this is from my uh
don't insult my stylist or his seeing
eye dog
but you know it's bad in New York the
Statue of Liberty used to have a torch
now she has a coffee cup with money in
it like dude this is embarrassing we're
supposed to be The Shining city on a
hill and now the only thing is shiny is
the pictures of people's feet they're
selling on only fans to pay for gas okay
it's not supposed to be that way there's
a lot of money in fate there's more
money in feet covered in pantyhose
you leave my search history
all right great to see you all thank you
for being with us all right straight
ahead tonight the 2024 GOP field got a
little bigger you'll meet the latest
entry Straight Ahead hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else